welcome to the wonderlands  a glorious fantasy realm chock full of  shooting  looting  and mystical magical smelly stuff  when you traverse these splendorius  lands it'll be up to you dear traveler  to class up and save the day  perhaps you fancy your hand at  stavamancy it's less magic and more a  way of thinking specifically how do i  stab that guy  [Music]  may haps by tossing out an ethereal  psychic ghost sword  stabbermancers are all about creating  and capitalizing on  opportunities  vis-a-vis  stabbing  or should you prefer a less subtle  approach the berzerker is for you  [Music]  see something  smash it  see something else smash that  unleash your frosty fury on fall after  fall  honestly it's therapeutic  that's just a taste of what we've got in  store for you there are plenty more ways  to play whatever your poison  we've got you covered  welcome to the wonderland  [Music]  [Music]  you